when you're hiding something you don't
want that and they are hiding a lot of
things they lied about that exchange and
fortnite unlike most people can prove it
he joins us tonight the importantly
thanks for coming on so you grew up in
Boston I think you probably grew up in a
family that took the New York Times
seriously you've lived in New York you
may live there now were you surprised by
this
no at this point I wasn't but what you
just said I talked to my dad who is
somebody who would I say trust the New
York Times yeah um and that's the alarm
and that's the alarming part because you
know in the way you just preface it I
reached out to her seven months ago
Tucker they've been doing this for
nearly a year I knew about this
investigation when I heard about I said
let's sit down open book I will answer
any question you have and the thing
about it and I don't care what your
politics are how you sit I am the
witness of a story you are working on
for basically a year and I am saying I
will sit down with you you can ask me
anything I'm not saying lawyers in the
room nobody just me I will answer every
single question you have she had no
interest in that she said I'm eager to
do it two weeks went by I didn't hear I
reached out again I said hey I'm still
here so she did this she worked on for
nearly a year and then she went ghost
crickets I didn't hear anything for so
seven months and I get the text the list
of questions that says hey we want all
these answers to all these allegations
in 48 hours it would be the equivalent
if this is a court case because that's
what the time is doing try to create a
case that I'm a scumbag and sway people
that you give one lawyer basically a
year to present the entire case why this
guy stinks and oh you have 30 seconds
now to defend yourself who would ever do
that who would nobody in there right
much he never had interest in telling
the truth all she wanted to do was build
a case against me she never talked to
any of my friends anybody who would
Advocate she never wanted to hear how we
do responsible gaming training at our
company it was all a hit piece and she
had no interest in hearing my side of
the story
what's so funny is it's about your
personal life and you've got a pretty
effervescent personal life but I've been
in the media for 31 years you hardly
have the creepiest personal life of
anyone in the media I mean because the
media these are creepy people why are
they trying to attack you on this
because you're disobedient right
yeah you know I think I've become
politicized a little bit but like what
you said listen I don't care if people
don't like me Tucker I really don't yeah
all I'm saying is give people the full
picture that's I yeah well I'm
disillusioned I know that's not what the
times does but how can you say this
woman has a Pulitzer they should take
that back break it and throw it in the
river like all I'm saying is let people
decide how can you do such a one-sided
hit piece and then say you're the New
York Times and you actually care about
honestly no you don't you're you're a
liberal rag that is just like everybody
else
that's totally true but you've got this
Legacy Prestige that I really hope you
do your best to tarnish because it's not
deserved Dave portnite thanks for coming
on tonight for catching them lying yet
again
thank you subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight